sie sind laut und schwer zu bändigen
die bunten mandl & krempel unheilige
begleiter des heiligen nikolaus zwölf
kilometer legen sie an diesem abend
zurück mit dabei der deutsche fotograf
karsten peter seit vielen jahren reist
er durch die alpen
unzählige bräuche und riten hatte in
dieser zeit fotografiert unheimlich von
der klangfülle
einfach bild und mystisch und das
ziemlich einfach an also seit
kindesalter hat nichts mit magie
fasziniert und der spüre ich einfach
nach
das ergebnis hat carsten peter in einem
bildband veröffentlicht
in alpen dämonen zeigte heimische
bräuche die an fremde kulturen erinnern
dabei stammen sie aus ländern wie
deutschland österreich und der schweiz
ich versuche irgendwie die originalität
von diesen posten zu filtern und
herauszugreifen also was wir vielfach in
vielen bereichen der alpen verloren
haben und ich hoffe irgendwie auch dafür
einzutreten also diese bräuche
schützenswert sind
man kann da auch nicht genug
aufmerksamkeit und sympathie dafür ein
jahrhunderte alter braucht er ein
eigenes kunsthandwerk hervorgebracht hat
maskenschnitzer philip watts arbeitet
das ganze jahr über den so genannten
orphan bis zu 450 euro kann eine solche
holzmaske kosten getragen wird sie nur
an einem tag im jahr bislang mit dem
ganzen für dieses das soll den leuten
schon ein bisschen einen schrecken
einjagen
das ist schon ein bisschen dazu darf
dass man etwas respekt vor dem ganzen
hat am späteren nachmittag wenn es
dunkel wird beraten sich die sogenannten
bassen auf den lauf vor auch bei der
rosenhof abbas steigt die aufregung
gerade werden die letzten bunten mandl
in stroh eingeschnürt
das ritual ist jedoch ein großes
geheimnis außenstehende sind unerwünscht
für die einheimischen aus dem ort ist
der buhmann lauf vor allem überliefertes
brauchtum
die jungen burschen wie das machen die
marken des nicht den tourismus oder für
die kurgäste sondern wirklich was ihnen
unheimlich spaß macht obwohl sehr
anstrengend ist aber sie waren praktisch
das ganze jahr drauf bin selber gelassen
das ist einfach wenn man die soße als
faszinierend das kleid was die haben
einfach ein paar schauer brauche eben
von gutem handel laufen
das ist heute schönen das gehört dazu
tropfen es geht los
querfeldein zieht der tross nun von haus
zu haus 18 mann zählt die rosenhof abbas
wer dazugehören will muss ledig und
männlich sein
wer nicht dazugehört sollte besser das
weite suchen
die wollen nicht dass sie fotografiert
werden wenn die laufen irgendwie vom
gesicht sind gibt es gibt alles möglich
also hin und wieder wird man geschlagen
man wird auch verprügelt
also die sind uns noch wohl gesund es
kann sich schnell ändern
aber der nikolaus bringt mit seinen
begleitern nicht nur ärger im haus von
familie beruf freuen sich die kinder auf
kleine geschenke guten mandel und trampe
sind dabei um den kindern respekt
einzuflößen
das immer wenn sie ganz klein sind sind
sie ganz unbefangen haben überhaupt
keine angst
danach hat man oft keine chance weil sie
vor lauter angst schreien und im jahr
darauf ist es wieder anders runde
höhepunkt des abends die ankunft der
weißen auf dem marktplatz im berggarten
wer jetzt noch unterwegs ist bekommt die
rote zu spüren
sie sind bild des gehört dazu
man muss nur den angst haben keine angst
haben dann umso härter das ist das ist
klar
also ich werde wahrscheinlich von
striemen übersät sein und ich werde den
man sieht schwarz im gesicht streben
überall aber die mühe lohnt sich wenn
ein bildband entsteht denn die eigene
tradition verblüffend fremd erscheinen
lässt